I'll push the button to have Joe Biden
resign and have Kamala Harris become
president right now I would love that I
gotta be honest I think kamalair Kamala
would be worse it's it's yes you know
what she's gonna do okay I would rather
have a president sleeping than to have
Kamal Harris go fire
is bad
and I'm here because of Fire
and everyone's gonna be like what that's
an interesting argument would you rather
have a vacant non-president or a bad
president that's like ruthless evil and
horrible just check it out
would would be there and he would do
better than both of them not by much but
he'd be like
if a fire in you people get hurt
fiberglass the the fire and I'm like
well I can see some indignation in his
voice and he asked for people to get
hurt so I'll take that water
on fire we understand yeah